[Music]
in cheating the system news submitted by
too many guides a woman was sentenced to
jail after scamming a wedding website
out of 10,000 wrecks waiting website a
wedding website she's standing the knot
it's that's a big website you heard of
it's huge like the wedding I don't know
much about weddings what exactly is a
wedding is a place where it's kind of
like um sort of like Yelp I guess for
wedding and like wedding planning so you
can find venues you can find
photographers you can find anything you
need and you can also create like your
wedding website where your guests can go
like see the invitation you could also I
create oh no it's almost like an Expedia
then huh I mean booked up because off
like our hotel what are all the things
you need well it's like Facebook element
I think if I remember correctly because
the last time I saw those were years ago
but yeah it's just like a place where
you it helps you plan your wedding any
are married I know what my except
relieved but yeah so the knots and so
this bride from here in California her
name is ver Mita who is 37 years old the
reason why I said it with a question
mark is because it's spelled very
interestingly how would you pronounce
that Roma titia remember Mattia whatever
with that so she ended up booking her
wedding reception at the Galleria
Ballroom in Glendale it would be Glenda
after she found this venue on the knot
and so the venue came with a 10k
insurance for event cancellation or
postponement horse that post post
[Music]
postponements as part of a collaboration
with the knots and with
insurance company and so after she
booked the venue she filed an insurance
claim alleging that she had tripped on
her wedding dress and she had to cancel
the reception because of her injuries so
she was able to provide medical
documents to back up her claims and so
she was then delivered a $10,000 check
from that insurance company for the
claim but you know what it should what
come higher right yes follow intro she
actually got away with it oh but then
this dumb bride thought that she could
get another 10k so what she did is she
emailed the insurance company saying
that her cheque was stolen and she said
them a copy of a police report to like
prove her claims again but then at that
point is when her claim was referred to
the Department of Insurance for
investigation at until that point and
then that's where both her medical
documents and the police report were
found to have been forged oh so then she
ended up getting a five-year jail
sentence because of this and she was hit
with a twenty two thousand five hundred
dollar fine and one count of insurance
fraud so oh man yeah five years and so
she just so exactly three years later
after her initial report I her initial
claim is when she said that she posted
on Facebook that that was her last day
free that she she said tomorrow I start
my 5-year sentence but I will only do
half I want all my support and family to
pray for me and my family what I don't
know it's weird okay I'm sad I have to
go but I will knock it out and come out
better and start from where I left off
with filming music and the businesses I
said I would start establishing that
more scamming yeah start at the
insurance co time I won't get caught
dying and it's a show one day show my
life through film to motivate others and
show the timeline for making mistakes
I'm gonna make an inspirational movie
about how I stole ten great
from insurance fo some movies come she's
writing a book right now she sounds like
one of those women who killed her
husband with antifreeze like one like at
one point and then like you know got the
insurance claim and then did again yeah
yeah it's not got too greedy you got
away with you once don't try the same
tactic in the same exact way the same
spot right same people I know you're
gonna say that she like did another like
wedding thing they did not like that she
said hey I lost my check now imagine if
she [ __ ] did something good with that
energy that she you should probably be
balling in a [ __ ] good ass way what's
a good insurance scam if you're doing it
for a good reason like to pay your
medical bills if you get back to to feed
an orphanage because you need to keep
the orphanage open and the government
won't pay you so you have to do
something scammy like Robin Hood
everyone loves Robin Hood you know be
cool with insurances if there was a way
cuz you know how every month we pay for
this thing that we don't even know if we
will ever need to use hi if there was
like some sort of clause in there where
it's like after X amount of time you get
X amount of money so at least it's not a
complete waste of like but then
obviously the insurance wouldn't want
this day farm that's of my debt like a
good not really that strong so like
that's that's how these insurance
companies become like the biggest
financial institutions of the world is
they already calculated statistically
one out of every personal breaker arm
here or attach a coherent their gambling
to show their gambling to pay but
they're doing it from the smart way or
they know that most people are just
gonna end up paying like 40 years with
their insurance maybe only cashing out
once or twice for the broken arm so
they're they're doing that across
millions of people that's how these
comes at you so huge [ __ ] insurance
companies and casinos have the same
business months that it's the exact same
boy right they make money but they're
not making like a killing compared to
other margins cuz if you look at hump
like I saw this one of AIG and I thought
they would make way [ __ ] more but
like for example like let's say if
they're making a hundred grand right
they're only making like
10 or 20 grand out of that that's the
profit goes to cover like Lance's yeah
yeah so like if if like let's say we had
an insurance pull together right and
then everyone's pitching in for like 400
bucks a month but if I get sick and then
you get sick and then they're paying for
both of us it kind of evens out that's
the gamble like let's just help these
[ __ ] don't get sick yeah so she
got caught now she has to do five years
in county jail permitido
[Music]
furniture when you finish your name you
think of plots to get back absolutely
for sure like this has been since five
years old she's well that's all that
that bullying resentment yeah like I'm
I'm gonna take him out psychologically I
wonder if it was originally like genuine
like she did trips she did fall she got
this and then she got the money and
she's all like well the Frog - oh
because I'll be a good movie if it came
as an accident like let's say all right
so I'm just writing the movie out in my
head right so her life was like she's
always been honest and everyone around
her has been doing shady [ __ ] you know I
mean and she's like you can't be like
that and she's down and out and she sees
all the her friends waning from being a
con or whatever and she's like [ __ ] and
then she actually breaks her leg and she
gets the money yeah and then she's like
hmm this is my gosh she gets a taste she
gets a taste and it wasn't even a con
and she does it again and again and
again you kind of have to okay let me be
out of the job the O do gate doesn't
$10,000 seem like that [ __ ] and I add
that doesn't like $2,000 that'll only
get you into the things that you really
want about it's a lot and a little at
the same is yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
like tenrecs especially if you if you
earned it and make take five what is it
like they'll take seven in California
like I gotta keep working I think the
reason for that is because the things
that we think about in terms of our
purchasing cuz when you're younger
you're thinking about oh man I can go
get that ps4 I can get like all these
days well but when you old are you like
oh that's really just like rants really
half a year
I saved four grand that [ __ ] took me
like six months and needs to save up and
I thought that was fast and I bought my
car with it and I was like Matt is the
most expensive thing I've ever bought
negative 300 all this money that's what
blew my mind is like you're telling me I
gotta pay hundreds of dollars a month
but I'm young and I don't have money you
sound like a number one draft pick
that's what you sound like right now is
that like you just got drafted by the
Washington Redskins in the third
ultimate draft and it's like yeah I
don't know but that's that when you're
yeah when you're young though it's just
you don't think it through it just right
no taxes nothing and so like ten
thousand I could understand why I'm sure
she try other little things first which
is like this [ __ ] worked so let me run
it back no I passed you did the exact
same scam Bush is like this time it's my
left ankle to ankles like a scammer she
just tweaked it a little bit these are
the same documents uneven change oh yeah
yeah just why don't wait out over the
White House that's why they say like
when you get too greedy that's when you
get caught every single time
yeah unless you have enough money to
cover now you can be greedy but you got
to come in with some money you know the
man like this can't be all of your dough
just ten thousand like it you got a
hundred thousand you could do with ten
thousand dollars can you need at least a
hundred hundred fifty thousand take five
thousand from somebody if all you got is
five thousand that's that's how the rich
get cuz how much did um the bank that
one thing they've scammed people had a
billion I think they paid like 62 may
JPMorgan has to play like a 62 million
out of five nobody went to jail and they
took billions credit one day trans you
hear some like that with the information
leak or whatever and they don't have all
those people yeah that money I get
emails and I don't even follow up
sometimes do you get the emails like
yeah there was some [ __ ]
you know the class action please $7 from
Toyota and I'll just yeah you people do
when eight when they air when they send
you that email follow-up man they gotta
pay the pettiness of making sure they
have to they don't like to pay a dime
make sure you get your seven dollars a
day yeah like cuz that'll had up until
other people tweet about forward my
email to you yeah everybody I will get
you that money you imagine if you just
had a business where you collect all of
that that's a million dollar idea
they do they do have those they have
they have like those independent like
not they're not debt collectors are like
settlement collectors and like they'll
do it I know a guy who does it for like
like the family of somebody who say your
uncle died then you hit him up and say
like did he have any money coming in his
way that he just neglected or something
like that and he'll find out and you
might get you a cemetery plot that you
didn't even know existed or a piece of
land is all you litter sale I don't know
I don't know no no but they are if you
googled it they'll they they go get that
I'm just gonna go up later how to get my
money that's not my money yeah yeah
there's somebody out there we'll gonna
go get whatever money you need I
recently had a letter of we were getting
like a thousand dollars back for over
paying taxes for a company that we took
out years ago and then I was and then on
the bottom it said a reason for like
return and I wrote down it's my money
it's by like reason for wanting the
returners or whatever the tax return
yeah I said it's my money and I just
said to back in did you get it I hope so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]